We are back from Ireland after a very long travel day.
Honestly, none of us ever got on Irish time while we were there,
I feel like we're not as jet lagged coming back as I had anticipated,
but it feels so good to be back to the farm.
Last night we went grocery shopping,
so we were ready for Charlie's birthday breakfast this morning.
We always do a big birthday spread for the kids birthdays,
and then
Daniel and I have a speaking event tonight we had to get ready for.
I had an interview that I had postponed from before the trip,
so I did that this afternoon
and then we were off. Our event was at the Grand America Hotel.
Daniel and I always get super nervous before we public speak,
and tonight was no different.
But we had fun telling our story.
I also shared our very first Instagram Stories
that we ever posted on Ballerina Farm.
It was the night we got our first four pigs,
so that was fun to go down memory lane.
And then we ended the night eating
at one of our very favorite restaurants in Utah,
which is Walters. We had their handmade pasta
and ended the night with the most delicious hot chocolate drink.
It was so good.